sur château que vous allez découvrir il
n'est pas vraiment caché là c'est une
perle de la région un lieu emblématique
et énigmatique
pourquoi cela seconde avant combien
carrément à l'intérieur alors c'est vrai
que c'est un château qui fait partie des
grandes oeuvres architecturales utopique
qui rend ce lieu très magique quand on
est sur la route en direction de cruzy
le châtel on ne le voit pas il faut
grimper un petit sentier est là quand on
arrive on voit cette masse imposante
majestueuse avec une à settat c'est un
endroit vraiment unique et en fait c'est
ce château a été construit sur une
maison forte qui date du xiiie siècle et
qui appartenait à la famille de
clermont-tonnerre
on va revenir sur mes histoires et puis
véritablement découvrir ce lieu
particulièrement marquants de notre
région mais d'abord je suis sûr que vous
avez entendu parler du loto du
patrimoine patrimoine
je dis souvent que nous avons notre
stéphane bern au féminin c'est marie
thérèse gars ça ici dans la région
le cru 2010 9 justement y avait ce lieu
emblématique de la région oui la preuve
en couleur et puis nous revenons pour en
parler ensemble regarde le château de
môle quand il a appris la nouvelle le
maire de cruzy le châtel a sauté de joie
le château de mono loto du patrimoine
une belle opportunité pour la commune se
retrouver à voir les tickets virée à
gratter ou en voir notre château à cruzy
le châtel on s'est quand même quelque
chose de jared dudley assez exclusif
c'est vraiment une grande une grande
chance et pour le territoire et pour le
village parce qu'on va parler on va
parler du village et surtout on va
récupérer des fonds pour terminer cette
bâtisse édifiée au xvième siècle pour la
comtesse de tonnerre ce château parts à
gonna let aujourd'hui classé monument
historique
claude le gardien du château le connaît
par coeur une des particularités de ce
château et année un puits central
entouré d'un escalier
ce puits nous permettait d'alimenter
tous les étages en eau et en même temps
et nous alimenté par la lumière en eau
laissé à l'abandon au cours du 19ème
siècle le château a beaucoup souffert
il faut attendre 1997 pour que le
département de l'yonne nouveau
propriétaire décide de le restaurer mais
en 2016 faux
budget les travaux s'arrêtent la
collectivité a besoin d'un million
d'euros pour reprendre le chantier les
deux tiers de la toiture et des façades
sont ont été faites
il reste encore deux façades a terminé
ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui c'est que
grâce à cette opération loto du
patrimoine on puisse se re commencer le
chantier et le terminer et pour la
sauvegarde du bâtiment complet après
bussy rabutin l'an dernier le château de
môle ne sera le deuxième monument
bourguignon a figuré sur les tickets à
gratter
en plus d'être sauvé il pourrait attirer
des milliers de visiteurs
supplémentaires
le château de maulnes dans l'yonne pour
le cru 2010 9 en attend avec impatience
évidemment le cru 2020 et je profite de
votre dextérité à faire le grand écart
facial sur toute la bourgogne franche
comté pour nous faire découvrir des
lieux emblématiques
si vous aviez quelque chose a suggéré à
stéphane bern pour le cru 2020 sachant
que château de môle est déjà presque à
une doc
un autre château méconnu des
bourguignons et des franc comtois
pourtant c'est l'histoire de notre c'est
vraiment le berceau de notre histoire
c'est le château de germolles en saône
et loire qui mériteraient encore aussi
un peu financements pour pouvoir
progresser dans la restauration parce
que c'est le dernier par le palais
princier qui restent en france et le
château de germolles pourquoi pas ça
sera peut-être l'occasion d'une
prochaine qu'on dit quand on retourne à
l'est d'auxerre entre tonnerre et
châtillon-sur-seine précisément à cruzy
le châtel au château de môle dans
l'yonne pour essayer de retracer son
histoire elle découvrir un peu plus de
solidaires on lève le voile alors ses
châteaux pourquoi il a cette forme
unique et vous avez vu il est construit
autour d'un puits central des appuis aux
mets un puits de lumière et l'architecte
d'ailleurs dont on ne connaît pas le nom
alors il est donc construit dans la
continuité du château de chambord dont
on ne connaît pas non plus à chambord le
nom de l'architecte
c'est un petit peu le prolongement et
quand on arrive on ne voit pas qu'il a 5
face à l'or ce château a été construit
par louise de clermont-tonnerre voyez
regardé 5 côté ego et au milieu on a ce
cet escalier qui tourne autour de ce
puits et toute la construction
ésotérique symbolique du pentagone qui
si le pentagone avec toute l'histoire
l'architecte s'est basé sur la géométrie
et le nombre voyez là on a l'ailé face
du château de de moon
et quand on est face à une de ses faces
on n'imagine pas donc cette forme
pentagonale les surfaces ouais donc
c'est louise de clermont-tonnerre qu'il
a fait construire avec son deuxième mari
louise de clément clermont tonnerre
alors très belle femme la cinquantaine
une érudite un bel esprit veuve la
premier mari un mug et catholique ça
c'est très important parce que elle va
épouser son second mari qui antoine de
crussol de crisolles 24 ans de moins
qu'elle
alors à l'époque c'est quand même assez
hors norme et et protestants et on est
en pleine guerre de religion puisque
quand ils vont faire poser la première
pierre du château de maulnes on est en
1566 alors ce château donc la louise de
clermont-tonnerre et antwan de crussol
n'habiteront quelques années plus tard
et vraiment on est dans une énigme
architectural et on est aussi dans un
château un lieu emblématique qu'a
inspirés des personnages se lève alors
en effet et il a inspiré par exemple
clemenceau le corbusier l'architecte le
corbusier
je me suis laissé dire que karl
lagerfeld jean christophe averty révèle
le couturier donc était très intéressé
par les le pentagone par le nombre 5 et
par les maisons pentagonale la voyez on
va ce puits qui au tout tourne autour de
ce puits il y à aussi patrice chéreau le
réalisateur qui a tourné dans ce château
de môle quelques scènes delà du film la
reine margot et le chanteur chemise à
fleurs à doëlan il faut m'expliquer
pourquoi antoine et bien parce qu'il est
très aussi à il aime bien tout ce qui
est un peu symbolique ésotérique
alchimique voilà ce sont des personnages
qui sont très intéressés par la
symbolique des nombres la géométrie et
il ya bien sûr le général pershing
le chef des armées américaines à loger a
séjourné au château de maulnes en 1917
et il a tellement impressionné par
l'architecturé de ce château que on dit
qu'il a été influencé et qu'il a
transmis pour plus tard la construction
les plans pour la construction du
pentagone le département
l'américain se trouve à arlington voilà
donc alors il ya un autre bâtiment
pentagonale on va dire mais qui ne
possède pas ce puits central et c'est
l'avis de la farnese à proximité de rome
qui a la même architecture et qui date
de la même époque
le château de maulnes à visiter
absolument alors à partir de l'année
prochaine puisque là il vient de fermer
pour la saison hivernale
voilà je peut plus l'arrêter vivre des
coups de coeur un chef-d'oeuvre de
l'architecturé de la renaissance le
château de môle dans l'yonne à cruzy le
châtel